yeah I saw you do like a breakdown of
like all the new [__] that's rolling out
and it's not just the Jason Lee show no
it's like uh you're doing a live stream
there's Jason Lee experience you're
doing like Monday through Friday there's
like gonna be something right so there's
the Jason Lee show and Revolt
um and you're the first person on this
whole run for people to ask me this
question because I think people are and
I love that people are focused on the
show but I what people when you made
that announcement I was like oh [__]
yeah that's that's a lot so the Jason
Lee show on Revolt we filmed we filmed
five episodes last last week before I
went on the Press tour but that's gonna
air once a week on Revolt 10 p.m Eastern
on remote TV cable then the audio for
that rolls out the day before and so
what was holding up the deal was trying
to figure out where's this audio gonna
live because I was also in the
negotiations for a podcast deal so the
audio now rolls out on the jsonly
podcast on Mondays at Arizona Revolt
cable on Tuesdays and then Revolt
YouTube on Wednesdays and the experience
is different because you get a 44 minute
cut down on Revolt but then you get like
cardi B we gave a 44 minute cut down on
mobile TV but then we did an hour and 27
minutes on remote YouTube so it's all
the stuff that you don't see on the TV
show you see on the YouTube and then
um I felt like okay what is it that I
don't want to be the talk show host or
the host that just talks to the audience
I want to hear from them what the [__]
they think about what we're talking
about so we created Jason Lee after dark
where that Wednesday when the YouTube
hits and everybody's seen heard it on
audio watch on cable watched on YouTube
they can then come into a live
experience I can watch what happens
lifestyle right environment at night and
we can be drinking and talking and fans
can come in on these questions video or
call in
talk their [__] and then the Jason Lee
podcast will air on Fridays and then and
so the the Jason Lee after dark will be
on Hollywood unlocked.com we have a paid
um a paid place or membership placement
right help me understand because I see a
lot of big podcasts are going the
direction of doing deals with revolt and
having their content Live on revolt's
YouTube channel I I'm sure that the
monetary uh compensation is the main
motivation for that
for you though it it you feel like a
really strategic guy yeah why not have
the Jason Lee show live on your own
channel that you own and you control
great I mean I know it's money but just
from like a person on that of the camera
like I'm just curious you know because I
see a lot of people do it yeah okay
that's a great question one um shout out
to the tavio Samuels the um CEO of
Revolt brilliant they're killing it
brilliant black man who believes in
culture who believes in Black creators
who believes in creators a culture
period and I've been really big on
ownership of your content being able to
create strategic Partnerships to elevate
your brand
um finding people who believe in you as
much as you believe in yourself into
tavio did that you know I talked about
um Faith over fear and being able to
have like the you know there was a fear
to like run up on Diddy for a deal or to
hit ditty for a deal and then I got over
that and I got his number and I caught
him directly and he put me with tavio
and Dion I just understand we've been
able to really craft a relationship with
Dion on The Daily on side and with them
on a Revolt what I love about them and
why I chose them over all the other
networks we're talking about is because
when we got into the weeds of the deal
ownership was important to me so I um I
shared the ownership of the content I
create with them but I own the show name
and I own a share in the profit of the
show equally so we're Partners I don't
work for them they don't work for me but
our teams have integrated and aligned in
a way where I went with a five-person
publicist team and there's six publicist
team and now there's 11 publicists
working on the show that only amplifies
the Jason Lee brand that only amplifies
the visibility and I love the fact that
they pay
they also do paid media as much as we do
earn media so the way we just work this
whole rollout with cardi over four
billion media Impressions over um
seven million
um social media Impressions uh trended
number two on no I saw I saw you post
like the email screenshot of like the
stats it was crazy just and that's the
first episode right we plan to keep
going so yeah I think the fact that they
believe in the ownership and of the
content was great I don't know why
everybody else did the money is good
well I won't say it's not but you know
what I've been offered deals where
people come to me and said what if we
offer you 15 million dollars to come
over here but we own all your content
outright you own are you [__] done
yeah [__] that no cause I can get the 15
minutes because because you're obviously
financially well off compared to like a
lot of people like I'm not in your
business but I'm you're not doing too
bad
um but you could easily
I mean you did it with Hollywood the
Hollywood unlocked show right yes but
you could easily have pulled off this
entire thing without revolt's help I
could have but free but but I do think
that this is also a lesson that like
some people get so hung up and being
like nah I got this I'm over here on my
own that it's like
you said strategic Partnerships that can
benefit what you're doing I think some
people especially in like hip-hop
culture are so like hung up on being
independent now and not necessarily like
sometimes it's very beneficial to
partner yeah because the bag is bigger
in the long run yeah but you got to pay
attention like pay attention to all the
grades that are out there because I'm
paying attention right we just got our
evaluation 50 million evaluation
congratulations that's all you guys just
locked down some funding for like 1.8
million dollars well it's a little bit
more than 1.7 but because of the way
it's structured we could only announce
the 1.7 now but there's more to come but
you know we have some really good
strategic Partners a lot of people offer
me money oh this that whatever I still
owe 90 of the company I still have
control of the company and I still I
make the 10 is uh investors correct okay
there's a group of people that are
strategic so you know again these are
people who you know have access to
billions of dollars have access to huge
infrastructure I just met with somebody
yesterday who was like don't close that
round until I can get in there and this
person I mean you're gonna open the
whole world up in terms of Brands so
when I look at how I built it you know
Jay-Z said you know somebody who you
know people are afraid to to sell equity
in their business I mean if do you want
to get to that billion dollar status
it's not about what you giveaway it's
about how you how you sell it off or how
do you allow people to get in
strategically so if I have 50 of a
company that's worth a billion dollars I
walk away 500 million or would you
rather have 100 of the companies worth a
million dollars right right so that
really you just have to decide what you
want to do and that for me was always
like I look at the Jay-Z's I look at
like the pub daddy is the best marketer
in the business if you followed his
career from Uptown and I followed it and
so to be able to be on a network that's
black owned that he's actually
greenlit and that detavio is leading I
mean also even like even Diddy Look to
Him like Diddy bad boy had Partners in
the main you know whoever their major
distributor I mean it's Ciroc there's a
lot liquor partner there Diddy's the
face of it but it's like he's an
extremely smart man and I'd be very
clear everybody's I don't have a
relationship with him like that right I
mean I got his number he's on text but I
we're not on the phone every day like I
am with other people I don't have that
relationship with him
um and I don't know where the
relationship will go and I don't know
what the future holds but for right now
I really just really love what we're
doing over there
you know we have uh we have ideas for
where we want to take the show of course
this is like we're dating now like we're
we're trying to see episode one is a
success that's for sure episode one was
colossal but you know that comes with a
lot of pressure what's episode two gonna
do you know or episode three but I don't
have any I'm not worried about it
because I know that I'm more locked into
this and I've been in anything I've ever
done